so I came down I'm crossing the valley
and I want to go up on this mountain
here next this is another mountain I'm
thinking about hunting on and I want to
see if there any sheep up there today
I'm just going to have to cross this
little creek here to get over to it it's
pretty cold out today
probably in the 30s or low 40s at the
most it's actually beautiful weather for
being out in the wood but it's not the
best weather for crossing creeks this
looks promising right here
not too deep but I definitely want to
take my boots and pants off just so I
don't get wet few snow flurries right
now it's pretty cold out now so I want
to stay dry if I can I'm in the habit of
travel light for one thing when you're
hunting you don't have a choice now
today I'm just scouting but when I come
out here sheep hunting I have to travel
light because I have to carry meat back
you got to carry sheep down off a
mountain like that all the way across
the valley back home it's the hardest
meat there is out here to get home
clothes dry
look it's a little deep Jesus Christ I
was a little deeper than I thought all
right
nothing to be afraid up this bit of
water
you
that's great go across that without
getting any more cloak left
it's June and it's snowing pretty
typical up here I see snow every month
of the year July is not common but in
early June it can snow quite a lot
I love this weather actually perfect for
trap
this is good [ __ ] terrain here when
sheep are threatened they like to climb
up into the rocks that's why you usually
find sheep very close to this kind of
terrain right here
sheep don't like to go far from the
clips they like to stay close by this
train because this is where they can
escape from predators and this is where
they can escape from me
sheep and climb places I can go